so we're going to make a video about ada
lovelace the world's first computer
programmer we're here in hutton just up
the road from the university of
nottingham
which is kind of our angle as to why
along with everybody else we're making a
video about ada is that actually she's
buried here in some mary magdalene
church
well she's really interesting and it's
quite clear that she was a very
formidable intellect people need role
models they need to see people who have
gone before but often those role models
get turned into sort of genius-like
figures who are kind of unattainable and
especially for women scientists where
there just historically haven't been
that many role models that's that's
partly the reason that we're in the
state that we are so there's often a
tendency to to turn someone like ada
lovelace try to try to insinuate that
they single-handedly solved an entire
field or invented an entire field when
that's not really the way science
generally works there's a big myth about
the lone genius
here we are in the chancel of mary
magdalene church here in hucknall and up
there on the wall is the plaque
commemorating
uh ada lovelace but of course she's not
buried up there she's down here in the
family vault or actually this is just
the entrance to the family vault
the actual burials are pretty much
beneath our feet the reason why she's
here
is because this is where her father
another very famous figure lord byron
famous poet is also buried and she
wanted to be buried alongside her father
so in fact there's a whole series of
coffins beneath our feet associated with
the family
and on the top of the pile of coffins
are ada's coffin and little byron's
coffin so lord baron very famous figure
great poet um and generally speaking
great poets tend to get buried in poet's
corner in westminster abbey or in some
pools lord byron was a sufficiently
controversial figure shall we say that
actually they didn't want him in
westminster abbey or some pools so he
ended up buried here in hutman which is
actually where the byron family is from
so it is actually the family vault which
is why he's there and then when when ada
died she wanted to be buried alongside
her father i think it's actually i think
it's rather nice that actually it's sort
of
subtle and understated and actually
quite a lot of the story you're going to
hear about ada is in some sense she's
she sort of hasn't got the credits you
deserve for what she did and so actually
this is a sort of an appropriate
illustration of that
but most of the time science is done by
people contributing to a field that's
already there taking it a little bit
further taking it in a different
direction
and that doesn't take away from anyone's
individual achievements but it just puts
them in context so in terms of ada
lovelace you know she did some really
really fascinating things and that
should absolutely be recognized because
in addition to doing those fascinating
things she was a product of her time and
quite a quite a a different figure for
that time and i think that should be
recognized as well there was clearly a
problem that there were not enough women
getting involved in science and
engineering
and so she's become a sort of a
figurehead for that aspect of things and
so she's sort of held up as an example
of somebody who really was at the
absolute top of the game in computing
before computing had even been invented
of course we don't have a lot of women
scientists from that time and you can
ask
why why historically has science have
all these lone geniuses of these myths
been been men
um and i think there's a few things to
recognize there
first that ada lovelace and people like
her women like her had a huge barrier
against them in terms of education and
just encouragement and reception so she
was actively pushing she was pushing she
got she got real solid pushback of
people trying to discourage her and she
had to fight against that she worked
with a guy called babbage who invented
mechanical computers effectively and in
fact he never built them i mean he he
designed them
but they were never actually built and
so she was kind of working on a virtual
machine in the sense that there wasn't
actually a machine to work on so babbage
designed this computer called the
analytical engine there was a write-up
about it
done by an italian engineer
who did a write-up in french about this
this fine invention
and someone suggested to ada lovelace
that there should be a translation of
this so that the british people could
actually see what this british person
had actually done so she translated from
french into english this description of
the analytical engine so description of
the computer but then she added a whole
series of notes of her own creation
underneath the translation and in fact
the notes are longer than the things she
translated so the main part of the
document is actually her notes and
within those notes she sort of gave the
first clear exposition of what this
computer actually did why it was
different from just a calculating
machine what an algorithm really was in
this context and even uh some examples
of the first algorithms so in some sense
the first ever computer programs well
you can think of babbage as being the
person who did the hardware and ada was
the person who did the software and of
course you know you need both to have an
effective computer so in that sense
they're both the heroes of the story on
the other hand the reason we do know
about her and the reason she is
remembered is that she was a woman of
extraordinary privilege
what i had going for is she was part of
the aristocracy and so she had a great
deal more freedom
and money to do things and introductions
to people and ability to move in society
that actually allowed her to contribute
in a way that the vast vast majority of
women weren't able to do at that time
she was prepared and she had the
background and she had
the
understanding that when this very
important moment when she first
encountered babbage and his ideas for
the difference engine
she recognized what that meant well
there's an interesting story if we go
back to her her father for a minute so
her father was lord byron and her mother
and father acrimoniously divorced
shortly after she was born in fact i
think she's the only legitimate
offspring of lord byron he had plenty of
other children but this was the only one
who was born in wedlock so they
acrimoniously divorced and
ada's mother
was completely fixated that she thought
that lord byron was completely crazy and
and she thought it was genetic and so
she was very worried that ada was going
to go crazy the way that she perceived
her ex-husband had gone crazy and so the
reason why ada became so immersed in
mathematics is because her mother was
desperately trying to keep her away from
poetry and literature and all the things
that she thought would bring out the
craziness the way they had in that poet
byron and so she was actually trained in
mathematics from a very early age
and that's the reason why she became so
fascinated by this area it was that
combination of you know personality hard
work preparation
privilege and luck that all had to come
together
to create someone who was able to
contribute it didn't mean that she was
remembered you know her ideas weren't
immediately adopted had they been
adopted the victorian age might have
been completely different um you know
some people say that that we might have
had an information age a steam-powered
information agent in the victorian era
she's been rediscovered um i mean it's
partly because there has been this
cultural change in
it really is now perceived as a serious
problem we need to solve as to why so
few women are interested in the sciences
in the engineering um and so there's
that side of it and also she's been
rediscovered and so there's been you
know books written about her plays and
all those kinds of things so it's just
sort of risen to consciousness in that
sense i mean there's clearly there's a
fascinating story around that and once
you've got people interested in a
fascinating story then you can lead on
into other things so in some sense you
know you shouldn't view her as
the only reason why women should be
interested in science and engineering is
ada lovelace but she's she's a very
useful hook in the sense that she
clearly is a fascinating person a genius
in her own right and once you get
interested in the that sort of more
personal story it leads into this wider
narrative of of women in engineering and
science
now it's coming down it comes down fast
okay so already the chamber is a very
low pressure now there's very very
little air in there now it's like almost
a factor of a million kind of down in
pressure all right so now we're going to
drop it in vacuum
and see what happens